our flight has gone down this is an
emergency and survived together
[Music]
die alone we're getting off this island
Captain Torrance flight Commander how
can I help you fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this captain
get them on board let's have a good
flight
right through the top of the storm
us to keep everybody in their seats no
exceptions all right
[Music]
we are dark
then we're done somewhere in the Jolo
Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
[Music]
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or saved
we don't know who it is listen carefully
this is an emergency I'm captain Brody
Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England
country
I gotta go after them my passengers my
responsibility
I'm gonna need your help you're gonna
need this
perform a militarism
you can see that
so why'd they lock you up no one cares
what really happened
they say redemption can be found in the
most unusual places
if you do this you'll probably never see
your family again what about their
families
I have a daughter and I have every
intention of making a home
they're going to come at us with
everything they've got
we're getting off this island
[Applause]
[Applause]